[MUSIC]
I remember my first study group,
we were from different continents,
different disciplines, we were a mix of
big corporations and entrepreneurs and
I thought how will we even find a common
language to define the task at hand.
But together, we come back to the most
efficient problem solving that I've
ever experienced and this continued
with every new study group and
in every discussion as
the program went along.
>> When you're talking about Cohort of
some of the most impressive executives all
around the world, they all bring different
capabilities, different experiences,
different approaches, different
culture to problems or situations.
And that bond with those classmates was
probably the most unexpected thing.
>> You get to interact with
such a diverse population and
I don't just mean in gender and ethnicity,
although yes, that is part of it.
But culturally and industry,
I got exposed to industries I had
never been exposed to at STP and
I also got exposed to
private companies to NGOs and
unless you are intentionally switching
industries in your career you,
we don't often get that opportunity.
>> It was really the network and the
strength of that network that came out of
the program and the lifelong relationships
that you build coming out of that program.
>> Having that that expanded
support network of both men and
women in leadership positions across
different industries, globally,
has made me better prepared for
both what I'm doing in my role today and
I think what I'm going to
be doing in the future.
[MUSIC]